[Music]
we didn't have the Internet in my house
okay for a long time and so I had a
friend who had the Internet and I would
always go over to his house and like the
idea that I could get on AOL Instant
Messenger yeah and talk to girls at my
school without having to speak to them
like with my actual voice blew my mind I
think my friend had AOL because she kept
getting like the discs yeah which was
just astounding now that you think about
it someone just nails you would just
that's like here's the new way oh well
and you're like well good guess I gotta
install this for the update yeah games
today
you're like a stack of pissed
could you imagine yeah you'd have to
call of duty yeah I got out of her house
just like you know listening to her yell
at her mom to not be on the phone and
she wanted to get onto AOL for just no
reason because she didn't you know she
was a kid so it's not like she had to
email or anything to check she would
really have anything to check she just
wanted to be like she had no reason to
be on the internet but her mom like had
actual people to call just like one
person being very logical and the child
is been like no but I wanted I remember
my dad got I think the reason we got the
Internet at my house was my dad wanted
to be able to work from home on Mondays
and I just remember mmm I just remember
that like cold sweat fear when you
forgot he was online he went to pick up
the phone I just knew it was important
and knew and this thing that I was used
to doing which was just picking up the
phone suddenly became this loaded
activity that I needed to check with my
bank do I make it sound like they're
scary they're very they're lovely
[Music]
okay yeah right that's it next question
you know I think a lot of people talk
about their community and how they have
the best community but we feel like we
have one of the best communities out
there
nice off with any other like fair how
about our people meets I don't have just
one big nice communities oh you are Oh
our community is is so pleasant which is
you know too many other YouTube channels
that you can find where it's just like
the worst comments sometimes to a
constant disaster disaster so you know
how you know the ratio for a lot of
videos is like 95% bad comments 3% just
why did you say this I don't even know
before you go there and then 2% like oh
that was a nice comment we have like the
reverse so nice 3% of I don't know what
this is
which humbles you a little bit nobody
needed to keep your home right
the show is kind of predicated on
audience suggestion it's like it started
with you know but the tagline is like we
take your dumb ideas and big even dumber
drawings so it automatically gives the
audience an end to be able to interact
with us like they've got a reason to go
down in the comments and talk to us yeah
you've got a better chance of us reading
your comment and responding to it if you
just leave us a suggestion of what to
draw
rather than cause a name and I think
that just sort of a little little trick
that sort of started us off before for
all these nice people sort of
congregated to it I think they just saw
the comments and they were if there were
mean comments they got buried and so
actually nice people came in or like oh
you can you just be nice here and then
yeah they've really they've taken it and
run with it and our most vocal fans are
just they're not just nice but they're
really funny and we had some of them on
like streams with us like some of the
fans that are particularly like you know
big fans yeah I got him on and they were
like funny and cool giving them the
opportunity to come a like to see with
you guys and be yeah yeah as well yeah
yeah it's fun and then people see that
and they're like well maybe if I'm also
cool and that it's like I'll get to do
that it's a kind of fosters this like
self fulfilling positivity prophesy no
it's cool yeah and our little our little
nice wholesome community has now decided
to like monitor itself so like you know
I we have a trophy discord and there was
one person who's just going in and kind
of trolling and a lot of the comments
were just like come on like do we're
just like here to hang out do you want
like do you want to talk about something
are you okay like you know they were
just like killing him with kindness
basically
there's probably like yeah you think it
Disney one that isn't he something no a
Star Wars film I saw that was the first
is that your choice I and I remember
this movie going experience because
halfway through up Harrison for the
first movie that I knew I wanted to see
in theaters that my parents wouldn't let
me was Jurassic Park oh dude that is as
a as a teenager the AFI did a screening
a few nights screening of Jurassic Park
in theaters so I did finally get to see
it in theaters how'd you finally saw
Jurassic Park in theaters it's very fun
to watch in theatres
[Music]
for me it literally was just I started
making comics in college for fun and
then I you know was enjoying it so I
just kept doing it yeah and you know
that kind of build it and I gained fans
through that and then spun that into a
job at CollegeHumor and then now from
CollegeHumor to drop me and so it's it's
it's literally for me always been just
like find a thing that I enjoy doing
that I want to do and passionate about
and keep doing the thing even when it's
like hardware it sucks or I'm not good
at that day you the only way to get
anything done is to do something to keep
doing it so well I think the best advice
you can follow it's just not easy advice
to follow yeah you could me like I have
a hard time with it all the time it also
sounds so boring oh yes like the most
true and it's as you said so hard to do
sometimes yeah cuz you just you have no
you get into a slump creatives tend to
fall into like a slump book but I can't
do today and I can't I couldn't do it
yesterday and now I can't do today maybe
I just shouldn't be doing the thing but
if you like to do the thing you'll
always find your way back to it just
keep going at them you know creatives
are also oftentimes their own worst
critics and I'd say to that is just like
don't expect the stuff you make to be as
good as you want it to be at first like
no one's is so you get better by doing
it even if you don't feel yourself
getting better if that makes sense
that's a long long process when you look
back on it you can just sort of see the
difference it doesn't doesn't only show
up right away yeah that's something we
tried to do on her show too is like turn
our own mistakes into like something fun
yeah it's like we're drawing and we'll
mess up and then we'll just roll the
mistake to make it into something new
and we've gotten a lot of like messages
from people an email saying like
watching us you know like laughs off our
art mistakes when we draw something like
genuinely bad sniff exciting funny we're
good yeah and so we'll just make the
episode about what an awful job we you
know laughing at that and having fun
with it it helps people to kind of get
out of their own heads
so I think that's a definitely a big
part to is just do the work and try to
stay out of your own head as much as you
can yeah we're always better than you
think you are
our sign-off on the show is we're sorry
and literally I started because I drew a
drawing that I was so unhappy with I was
like I can't believe we're posting this
on the internet for people to see I have
to apologize wrote the drawing saying
I'm sorry they had a little word bubble
out of his mouth and that that ended up
sticking it was just a catch-all for
we're sorry for for everything
we're sorry sorry sorry